are they reality TV stars or dietitians because
I feel like our standard for good nutrition
education sources is getting seriously skewed hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's [Music]
Kitchen today I'm going to be reviewing a handful
of popular celebrity-owned Wellness food and
supplement Brands to give you my honest thoughts
on if they're a goodbye or total bunk if you're
new here I'm a nobs dietitian so please don't
forget to smash that subscribe button for more
evidence-based nutrition advice and a check out
my description for a free Hunger crushing combo
ebook but quick let's talk carbs here specifically
bread because your girl loves her bread there are
a lot of healthy bread products out there and
if I'm honest most taste like cardboard they
definitely do not taste like bread so I was
shocked when I tried my first loaf of herob
bread bread they describe themselves as real bread
with benefits and that's really exactly how I see
their products too hero Bread is made with real
olive oil wheat plant-based protein and flax with
5 to 11 gram of protein and tons of fiber from
Prebiotic resistant starch they have sandwich
bread buns tortillas Brio sliders even croissants
like I've never seen a croissant with health
benefits but again I don't really care if a food
is the equivalent of a multivitamin if it doesn't
doesn't taste good it's not for me but believe
me when I say this bread is so soft and fluffy
the seated bread is perfect for sandwiches and the
tortillas are amazing for breakfast wraps and like
most of you herob bread has some near intentions
that they've set they want to improve their heart
health with their olive oil Rich recipes they
want to make more buttery delicious croissants
which you know I'm here for and they want to come
up with new Innovative bread products please can
we do pizza dough just saying but we already know
how important protein and fiber are in my Hunger
crushing combo and herob bread is such a foolproof
way to get both so if you want to try out herob
bread yourself definitely hit up my description
for my link herob breed is offering all of my
followers 10% off of their first order if you go
to hero. slabby and use my code Abby so according
to report by jll research celebrities these days
have been very busy doing some things that they
are maybe not technically qualified to do but
nearly 60% of celebrity brands on the market today
were founded in the last 6 years and I mean that
makes total sense with the rise of social media
and marketers ability to use user data celebs went
from being paid by a brand to endorse a brand or
appear in their commercial to then realizing why
endorse someone else's products when I can use my
celebrity status and be the face of my own and
I mean I think that's a really great move in my
books Kim K didn't become a billionaire being the
front of someone else's panties now even though
we sometimes get to see BTS marketing content
suggesting that these celebs are super Hands-On it
is really impossible to know if this is just for
show or if they are legitimately heavily involved
I mean remember the time that Kylie Jenner got
called out for staging pictures of her creating
makeup magic it was a super cute photo op but it
really didn't bode well for her legitimacy and
Trust even if she is actually heavily involved
in her makeup company and I'm sure that they're
all on the important calls and are testing to
give the final thumbs up but unless they're
like hiding their chemistry degree on their CV
there's a good chance that their R&D involvement
is relatively low lift and how could that not be
like I'm sure the Kardashians know what probiotics
are but do they understand how different unique
strains perform in different mediums and do they
know exactly how many cfus you need or do they
know how to interpret high quality research on
ingredients I mean this stuff actually matters
but speaking of the Kardashian Empire let's take
a look at Courtney Kardashian's recent supplement
brand lemi so Courtney's quickly expanding vitamin
Empire has 12 different products at the time
of filming there are way too many to get into
individually here so I thought I would Zone
in on one of their alleged best sellers the ly
perr AKA a probiotic for your lady flow I mean
whether or not Corney was actually Hands-On
this one feels definitely on brand but with a
zippy pineapple flavor purr promises to support
healthy vaginal pH balance and improve the smell
and taste of Little Miss minky M I'm intrigued
so one serving of gummies contains 1 billion
cfus of basilis coagulin snz 1969 plus 20 Mig
of vitamin C and some pineapple powder assumedly
for flavor fun fact but it was allegedly Kim K
who like started the bunk rumor that pineapples
make your kitty taste sweet but believe it or not
there's no evidence that it works nor should we
really want our lady flower to be smelling like
flowers I mean it's all right like as for the
active ingredients snz 1969 is a really great
spore-based probiotic largely studied for IBS
and digestion but there's only one study to
my knowledge that evaluated its efficacy for
vaginal Health this study looked specifically
at women with a yeast infection and found
that a combination of the probiotic plus an
antibiotic improves symptoms faster than an
antibiotic alone which makes total sense to
me since antibiotics can be really tough on our
microflora and ultimately probiotics I can help
that but if you don't have a yeast infection
and you're not taking antibiotics for it I
really wouldn't count on your basic Carnation
miraculously blossoming into a fragrant summer
rose if you get what I'm saying now it also
contains 20 Mig of vitamin C which is kind
of sort of associated with improved vaginal
microflora but the dose needed for that is
over 10 times what is in your gummies and you're
supposed to insert it like a suppository not chew
it like a piece of candy you get away from my
no so again not really sure this will do now
generally speaking I don't love gummy vitamins
since most gummies need to be sprayed with the
vitamins which can lead to huge inconsistencies
and stability challenges which is one of the
reasons why when tested gummy multivitamins tend
to score really really poorly reality is I don't
think these gummies can do harm like I said
I love basilis coagulant probiotics but in my
opinion as a dietitian the probiotic is really
the only functional ingredient here and it's
functional for reasons completely unrelated to a
nicer smelling vag and to pay $42 for literally
just 1 billion cfus which is honestly not a lot
and may or may not be super stable in gummy form
seems honestly quite criminal to me so sadly
no the let me purr does not pass my sniff test
but moving on to a wellness food product let's
talk about goodles by galado so if you're a
craft mac and cheese lover or what US Canadians
call KD this healthier box mac and cheese from
founder galado sounds like an answered prayer but
is it too good to be true well let's take a look
so goodles which I guess I figure is like a word
play on Good noodles is made from a combination
of wheat and chickpea protein along with whole
food vitamins from a wide range of different fuits
veggies and seeds and the cheese is made from real
dairy in the original and cashews and nutritional
yeast in the vegan version the result here is a
box mac and cheese with 270 calories 7 G of fiber
and 15 g of protein per serving along with a wide
range of micronutrients it's not like a complete
multivitamin by any means but I would say it's a
pretty good start I'm I mean especially love that
we've got some calcium vitamin D and iron now
the OG KD has an extra 100 calories per serving
and only has 2 G of fiber and 11 g of protein
now it doesn't offer nearly as many nutrients
but interestingly some of the nutrients it does
contain are offered in slightly higher amounts so
for example 46% riboflavin in KD versus 25% in the
goles but generally speaking the nutrients that
KD contains are not really nutrients of concern
at least to me so goodles does have an obvious
nutritional Edge I've also tried these and I do
think that they are legitimately pretty damn good
so goodles are definitely Abby approved though
if you love your KD and let's be honest sometimes
that fake cheese flavor is all that will do so
my tip is to try amping it up with some steamed
broccoli or cauliflower for some Fiber and some
leftover chicken or ped cottage cheese for some
protein all right folks moving on to kinu Forex by
Bella Hadid if you went a bit crazy on the festive
cocktails this holiday season and are resolving to
cut back on your alcohol consumption you might be
looking for some non-alcoholic bevies to switch
things up bellah hadid's kinu Forks claims to be
a non-alcoholic functional beverage designed using
adaptogens to help you manage stress neut Tropics
for brain cognition and spirit centered Botanicals
to elevate taste some lofty claims for Like a
Virgin drink mix so let's take a look there are a
number of products now in their lineup but let's
focus on the OG high road which is described as
helping you conjure captivating conversation and
release contagious energy that flows out to those
around you and reverberates Beyond what okay so
naturally all the functional ingredients are piled
together in a proprietary blend and while these
ingredients definitely have powerful benefits I
am skeptical of their efficacy in a product like
this so according to their website they add Gaba
to reduce stress even though a systematic review
found very limited evidence that it has any stress
relieving benefits and if it does studies are
using doses up to 100 mg or more can also includes
the adaptogen riola to apparently Boost energy and
vibrancy the energy claim yes but vibrancy kind
of just Mar marketing BS riola has been shown
to have benefits for stress and fatigue though the
research we do have requires a pretty high dose of
around 400 mg and then we have 5 HTP in there to
apparently Elevate Joy I don't know who wrote this
website copy but I assume this is like a super
wooy non-scientific way to say that increases
serotonin and reduces symptoms of depression
which 5htp is actually very effective at doing
but again the dose is usually between 300 and 500
milligrams and if we look at this 595 milligram
proprietary blend that contains these three active
ingredients plus an additional five ingredients in
the mix and then compare it to the combined 1,000
mgram clinical dose I just described it is very
unlikely that any of the active ingredients
are anywhere close to their clinical dosages
translation probably not going to do that said if
you like the taste and you're trying to cut back
on booze maybe it is worth the $40 USD for eight
servings but if you're looking for legitimate
stress energy and mood boosting benefits you are
much better off buying these supplements at full
dose or experimenting with non-s supplement
options like exercise and meditation so yeah
this one's getting the P for me now moving on
to Kate Hudson's In Bloom supplement line first
of all I love The Branding and I mean Kate is a
natural beauty so it's really not surprising that
her products do well but let's take a look at her
best-selling immune defense blend first off don't
love the slightly dishonest marketing I mean
nothing will boost your immune system and if it
did all these celebrities would have debilitating
autoimmune disorders because that is what happens
when your immune system is working on overdrive
but moving on in Bloom's immune blend basically
consists of a handful of antioxidant Rich vital
ingredients including Acero astralis Elderberry
Licorice and ginger and honestly I think all of
these are pretty great picks for immune support
asera is largely going to be contributing the
antioxidants and the mega dose of vitamin C we
see here which by the way you are mostly just
peeing out and then astrologus and Elderberry
do offer some evidence for immune support but
at relatively very high doses less is known in
highquality human research on licorice ginger for
immune and infection protection ction but data on
mice fish and test tubes show that licorice may
offer some powerful immune support and while
the human research suggested it may improve
upper respiratory tract infections patients
were given a high does Ivy drip not an oral
supplement same with ginger I mean Ginger is
packed with anti-inflammatory and antioxidant
power that enhance our immune responses in test
tubes and animals but we actually don't have any
highquality human evidence that actually prevent
vents infections or illnesses that doesn't mean
that these things don't work they probably all do
help but if I were to add up the clinical doses
of all of these potential immune modulators we
would be looking at between 7,000 to 13,000
milligrams which might be significantly less
than what is in this proprietary blend now
the better immune supporting bang for your
buck is actually in the trio of immune supporting
nutrients it has so vitamin C vitamin D and zinc
honestly she could have just sold the supplement
with those three vitamins for a fraction of the
price and it probably would work more or less
the same so yeah I will technically call this
Abby approved because I think it does contain
some key nutrients that probably does help to
support a healthy immune system but at $69 per
small jar I do think it would have been better
to have higher clinical doses of fewer functional
ingredients but if you guys are curious about any
kind of specific celebrity backed Wellness brand
definitely leave me a comment below I will try to
get to it in an upcoming episode and on that note
folks that's all that I have for you guys today
if you like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up don't forget to subscribe hit up my
description for a free Hunger crushion combo ebook
and I will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music] bye